[Applause]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you
custom made
the maestro now this character
is kind of misunderstood
and i got a greater understanding this
year when they came out with a series
entitled the maestro 2020 right
but let's talk about where he came from
the maestro came from the future
imperfect
uh he is made by peter davis and george
perez
and in that uh comic book
the they sent back
a warrior from the future to go
retrieve the incredible hulk at that
time he was working for the pantheon
and that's when he's dot green
now for those people who don't know who
dot green is
that's the incredible hulk where
he doesn't get madder and stronger he
didn't get stronger as he get madder
um he has a fixed power level
he's even killed he's uh bruce banner
in control of the hulk like you've seen
in the mcu
it's a very weird dynamic so he has a
fixed cap level on his power
so they send this warrior back in time
to go
retrieve him to go fight what we were
called
at that time the maestro
now he rules a city called
dystopia and he fought the hulk he was
stronger than the hulk
at the end of the day the hulk
outsmarted him
and basically took him back to where
he originated from and killed him off
that didn't stick so now
[Music]
we have where this fan art came from
the cover future imperfect war zones
from secret wars and
this book was so impactful to me because
this is when dr doom became
god doom and
he collapsed to multiverse into one
world and you had battle world
made of different uh times and spaces
and in this time maestro
ruled over dystopia with a little
different
uh storyline to it
so one of the best parts of this story
is when he fights the thing and it's
a very brutal visceral fight an
incredible fight
but this is not benjamin grimm
no this isn't this is general
ross
the stories has changed a little bit
because this world
is made by doctordome and he
fights the thing and the thing doesn't
have the hard
as you can tell here he's still that you
know like that soft looking
putty clay-like thing he doesn't have
the hard rock formation yet
that he gains later on so
you're fighting general ross
versus the hulk and this
hulk the maestro is
super strong because he absorbed all the
radiation
of the future from the nuclear holocaust
and he has all the knowledge
what you see here is his conquest
so i love that storyline but let's get
into this statue
this is a big boy he comes into many
pieces
this is like 40 something pieces because
the base
is made up of the heads of
all the dead heroes you can see
and villains you can see electro you can
see
doc ock you can see magneto
you can see iron man you can see uh
nova spiderman the falcon
thor's hammer you can see
pretty much every hero in almost every
villain
that's here dr strange captain america
shield
and they did a great depiction of
this right here this cover this fan art
his eyes is immaculate the colors on
his skin is incredible they even got the
pants color right
from the cover the fingernails look
great you always gotta have
great fingernails and toenails to get
this across the beard looks incredible
even the little chain that he has with
the gold
rims is depicted well the vainage
the musculature all of the character is
there the hands are
ginormous as you can tell it's a very
big
statue and it's an incredibly great
statue
i love everything about the statue like
i said it's a
big heavy statue and it's one of my
grails that i love
so much and i will be displaying him
as one of my centerpieces for my hulk
collection
well this is the part in the video where
i'm gonna tell you to
like follow and subscribe and also hit
the join button
hit that joy button you know where that
joint button is it's right there down at
the bottom
so when you hit the join button you can
see everything that we have in the realm
what we have going forward with uh lords
of gaming.net
where all our writers are and we also
have dolph castle x unboxings that you
can check out sundays
at uh i mean uh fridays at 9 00 p.m
sunday's design large podcast sorry i do
apologize but
we're bringing communities closer we're
working harder
and today for the special holiday uh
episode i would like you to stick around
because i have something very special
for you guys
so you can see the statue in all his
glory listen to the music
but it's a special bonus episode
that i want you to check out because i
get a chance to talk about
one of my favorite characters so see you
soon
take care stay collecting
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
oh
and like i said i wanted to give you
something special for the holidays so on
the last episode of dolph castlex
that uh i'm a part of fridays
at 9pm uh i did a live unboxing
of the asset of the
child and they give you a great little
uh greetings from sideshow
and it says congratulations on acquiring
the asset
and if you guys aren't familiar
this is grogo he's from the mandalorian
and from the first episode that i saw
the mandalorian
i knew i was going to love this
character he is from
the race that in star wars
uh yoda is a part of a part of and
yattle
those are the only two of his race
i don't even know what his race is
called uh so when i did see him
i called him baby yoda and for a long
time
i was like baby yoda baby baby yoda
and he's such a great part
of the mandalorian well at the end of
season two
uh some things happened and
grogel's journey has begun
so let's get into this statue
because this is a statue and it's a
life-size statue
of the child he comes with
a little magnetized
ball that he would always take
from the mandalorian in his ship
it goes to the ship as a knob so
beautiful
nice little touch so the base is a
normal star wars base
uh it looks very futuristic but uh
simplistic his clothes
his clothing is material so it's like a
sherlin type of material
as you can see you can see his little
feet there
i'm not going to do what everybody else
does and show
what's under his uh his show his naked
little body
you know he doesn't have anything down
there so y'all can
get the nastiness out of your head now
he has little
pieces of hair in his head his
eyes are glossy and like you can see him
his little cheeks are rosy and his
little chin is up
with his little mouth looking absolutely
so cute
you see his little nails and his little
fingers and his little nails is kind of
sharp
um he is
what i wanted him to be i waited so long
to get him in
and i just wanted to share this with you
so you can go see the live unboxing like
i said on the last episode of darth
castle x
uh and i did a live unboxing
it took me all of probably five minutes
he's one piece
in the box you take them out and then
there's the base
and there's a little nurb uh that he has
his clothing is nice nice material
he's made of uh a nice like
plastic type resin type something
substance his little hairs are there a
little gray hairs because he's 50 years
old
but um i wanted to share this with you
in this holiday season you know
everybody
give love reflect
stay with family because um
watching the mandalorian and his bond
with the mandalorian is such a great
thing
so hey guys stay collecting i'm happy
that you got a chance to see this
and i see you with a next statue
that is incredible
and a holy grail
for me i know you guys hear that a lot
but
i have a lot of grills on my collection
but this one
is truly transforming
my opinion as we speak
he's over there stay collecting
[Music]
you